sexy jeans fizzy drinks and the most
memorable diabetes spokesman to hit the
small screen these TV commercial actors
might be gone but they're definitely not
forgotten the forever face of Kentucky
Fried Chicken Colonel Harland David
Sanders who was not an actual military
Colonel though granted the honorary
title was born in 1890 but it wasn't
until 1930 that he'd get his start in
the Fried Chicken business his first
attempt at a restaurant was the Harland
Sanders Cafe in Corbin Kentucky where he
came up with this trademark secret
recipe and the rest is fingerlicking
good history but in the early 1960s
Colonel Sanders so Kentucky Fried
Chicken to two Kentucky based
businessmen nevertheless he still
believed in his product and stayed on
with the company as its official brand
ambassador into the 1970s tragically the
colonel died of leukemia on December
16th 1980 at age 90 though his legacy
lives on throughout KFC even if the
company's current standards don't live
up to his own nowadays there are
countless actors who have played a
fictionalized version of Colonel Sanders
in KFC's subsequent ad campaign complete
with the trademark white shrimp hey
that's not the real Colonel Sanders I'm
the real Colonel Sanders no doubt
Sanders's likeness lives on Far Beyond
his death hoping to generate more male
buyers the cigarette company Marboro
began an advertisement campaign in 1955
that has long supported the brand
capitalizing on the popularity and
masculinity of the western cowboy
Marlboro developed its own hero the
Marboro man who was brought to life by a
number of actors though perhaps most
notably by Robert Bob Norris cast
because of his friendship with Western
icon John Wayne Norris played the
smoking Cowboy for over a decade before
Calling it Quits ending his tenure for
an honorable reason turns out Norris
never smoked and he didn't want his kids
to either so when his son asked why he
starred in Marboro commercials if he
didn't want his children to smoke Norris
quit the very next day Having learned
from his father's example Norris's son
Bobby told an NBC News affiliate there's
no great area between right and wrong
you do the right thing even if it costs
you having never smoked a day in his
life Norris continued cowboying until
his death on November 3rd 2019 at age 90
the former maror man lived a very full
life beyond the cigarette campaign
supporting the Arts philanthropic
Endeavors and animal causes turns out
this cowboy was something of a hero
after all it's rare that an actor can
take a fictional character and spread
them Beyond a single brand but for a
comic like Jim vanney it was a piece of
cake in 1980 vanney teamed up with
nashville-based advertising agency
Cardin and Jerry to create a character
called Ernest whose popularity quickly
exploded soon Varney's Earnest became
the face of sprite check cereals and
even Taco Johns as ernest's popularity
grew overnight vanney became the star of
a plethora of tv specials feature films
and a shortlived TV series titled hey
Vern it's Ernest Vern uh I'm trapped in
here with all this Purity ice
cream don't send help you know what I
mean sure vanney was known for other
movie and TV roles too like voicing
Slinky Dog in the first two Toy Story
movies but Ernest stood in a category
all in his own unfortunately as an
active chain smoker vanney developed an
aggressive lung cancer in the late '90s
that soon ended his budding career in
2022 Barney's nephew Justin Lloyd noted
he really didn't want anybody to really
know how sick he was it wasn't long
before vanney died on February 10th 2000
at age 50 nevertheless Ernest remains
one of the most popular characters to be
born of an ad campaign and one with an
extensive Legacy borne William Daryl
Mays JR this infomercial King as he was
often called was best known as Billy ma
of oxyclean Fame known for his
boisterous personality and convincing
sales tactics May started at the Home
Shopping Network before landing the
oxyclean campaign at the turn of the
century called a full volume pitch man
amped up like a candidate for a
tranquilizer gun takedown by The
Washington Post there's no doubt that
Maize made a significant impact on his
field and was often imitated parody and
praised but wait there's more Maize also
started along Anthony Sullivan on the
Discovery Channel docu series pitchman
which followed the TV salesman as they
push different products in each episode
unfortunately the show didn't last long
as Maize died on June 28th 2009 at age
15 though initial reports claimed that
drug abuse was involved a later autopsy
denied those allegations citing heart
disease as the leading factor in honor
of maize many of his unaired commercials
were shown following the news of his
death and pitchman even aired a special
Billy Mae tribute in July 2009 Jeffrey
holder might be most notable for his
role as the villainous Baron SDI in the
James Bond Thriller Liv in Let Die but
he was also the pushman for seven up for
a Time reminding audiences everywhere
that 7even up has has no artificial
coloring or flavors and never will
holder's face became synonymous with the
brand during the 1970s and 80s
throughout the uncola campaign holder
sensual charm and distinctive chuckle
were trademarks for the brand which only
served as a publicity boost for the
rising star but holder's career was much
larger than his contributions to the
soft drink industry the actor won two
Tony Awards as a director and costume
designer for the original 1975 Broadway
production of The Wiz and all black soul
interpretation of The Wizard of Oz no
matter what role he was undertaking he
always put in the work to make it right
back in 1975 he told People magazine I'm
no snob the commercial is an art form
unto itself after all you are seducing
people no doubt he certainly knew how to
sell a product however even a talent
such as holder can't live forever due to
a complication involving pneumonia the
multi-talented artist died on October
5th 2014 at age
84 speaking of actors known for much
more than their work on television
commercials Paul Winchell was one of the
most accomplished ventriloquists
Comedians and actors of the 20th century
the voice of Winnie the Pooh character
Tigger Hannah Barbara's Dick Dastardly
and Gargamel from The Smurfs Winchell's
voice talents were exceptional and
that's not even acknowledging his live
action work but for our purposes
winchill is known for having also voiced
the trademark cap wearing Mr Owl in the
original Tootsie Roll Pop commercials Mr
Owl how many licks does it take to get
to the Tootsie Roll center of a Tootsie
Pop a good question question let's find
out though there is still some real
debate on how many licks it takes to get
to the center of a Tootsie Roll pop we
will always remember the animated bird
that first gave it a shot Winchell died
of natural causes on June 24th 2005 at
the age of 82 survived by his wife
children and grandchildren the following
day his estranged daughter April
winchill shared my father was a very
troubled and unhappy man if there is
another place after this one it is my
hope that he now has the peace that
eluded him on Earth today advertisements
for jeans are usually pretty silly but
back in the mid1 1980s Levi's
commercials were meant to be stylish
sleek and above all sexy that's where
model singer and soon to be TV
commercial star Nick Cayman came in
Cayman was cast by Levi Strauss and
Company as their frontman for a series
of commercials centered on branding
their Levis 501 Originals as the most
attractive set of denim jeans imaginable
no wonder this guy became a sex symbol
originally born Ivor Neville Cayman the
levite brand ambassador was later
noticed by Madonna who had him record
each time you break my heart leading to
his own musical career after four studio
albums Cayman dropped off the face of
the musical Earth it wasn't until the
2020s that we heard from the pop star
again only to tragically catch wind of
his death Cayman died on May 4th 2021
after a long battle with bone marrow
cancer he was 59 years old as reported
by the Herold Scotland came and once
expressed I guess because of the advert
people recognize me and then it's hard
then to be accepted as something else
still Cayman was thankful for the career
he did have even if his status as a pop
star was relatively
short-lived having been everything from
an actor and stuntman to a ranch hand
and a US Marine wolfred Brimley is
probably best known for his commercial
work for Liberty Medical and his
consistent advocacy for diabetes related
education that's right Brimley is the
diabetes guy who always warmed our
hearts whenever on screen the same one
John Goodman parody on Saturday Night
Live
hi I'm Wilford Brimley and I've had
diabetes for about 20 years he was also
the usual face of the Quaker Oats
company which felt on brand considering
his stance against diabetes and appeared
in films such as the thing cocoon and
the firm Brimley may have begun his
onscreen career in Hollywood but it was
his advocacy later in life after his own
diabetes diagnosis that made him a
household name or at least the guy you
remember who says the word diabetes
funny in 200 8 the American Diabetes
Association honored him with a lifetime
achievement to thank him for his
commitment to destigmatizing the
condition on August 1st 2020 Brimley
died at the ripe old age of 85 due to
complications from a kidney condition
brimley's agent Linda binsky told
Entertainment Tonight following his
death Wilford Brimley was a man you
could trust he said what he meant and he
meant what he said he had a Gruff
exterior and a tender heart it may
surprise folks to learn that long before
Dave Thomas was the founder of wind he
first ran a number of KFC franchises
working very closely with its founder
Colonel Sanders that's right much of
what Thomas learned about the fast food
business he learned from the colonel but
Thomas's dream was always to own his own
hamburger joint and so in 1969 he opened
Wendy's Old Fashioned Hamburgers from
there Wendy's became one of the largest
fast food chains in the world taking
some cues from the KFC Playbook Thomas
appeared in more than 800 Wendy's
commercials earning the Guinness world
record for longest running television
advertising campaign starring a company
founder Thomas might not be as
recognizable as Colonel Sanders but he
certainly put in the hours to make it
big sadly Dave Thomas died on January
8th 2002 at age 69 of liver cancer but
not before founding the Dave Thomas
foundation for adoption in 1992 hoping
to make adoption more accessible for all
to this day Thomas's daughter Melinda
continues to support Wendy's going by
Wendy Thomas when playing the burger
joints official
spokesperson generally known as a child
star in the 19 30s and 40s Jane Withers
eventually graduated to playing
Josephine the plumber a cousin of sorts
to Mr Clean who pushed the comic
cleanser on television for about a
decade in the 1960s and70s Withers was
instantly recognizable as Josephine a
role she landed the same year she earned
her star in the Hollywood Walk of Fame
when she wasn't selling Comet to
unsuspecting viewers Withers had quite
the career having gone from a child star
opposite Shirley Temple to Landing a
role in giant she continued working into
the 21st century with animated rle at
Disney surrounded by loved ones Withers
died on August 7th 2021 at her home in
Burbank at the age of 95 withers's
daughter expressed afterward she lit up
a room with her laughter but she
especially radiated joy and thankfulness
when talking about the career she so
loved and how lucky she was talk about a
really special
[Music]
lady